on va jouer tout de suite à qui veut
gagner des milliers tatatata tout
le principe est simple des questions des
propositions de l'argent gagné dix mille
euros à gagner peut-être pour les
hôpitaux de paris et les hôpitaux de
france qui sont pleinement mobilisés
bien sûr dans cette crise du corona
crise alors les chéris il y aura des
questions et d'y pallier à 500 euros et
à 1500 euros 3 joker la pelle à merde
c'est à dire que on verra si bouder à la
réponse l'arrêt fonction piste la
réponse se trouvera sur le nez de gilles
verdez et l'appel à un ami
un pote à moi donc un village virage
appellera un ami pour lui demander si il
a l'art et celle habile à ma chérie qui
va jouer avec lui vous savez que je suis
fan de nabila de la dore d'ailleurs
embrasse fort aussi touba qui est mon
frérot d'avis que j'aime aussi me et les
chéris vous êtes une habile à dubaï dans
ma chérie oui je te que je vous fais des
gros bisous à tous les deux merci d'être
là et vous savez que je vous aime et
j'ai hâte de vous voir tous les deux et
pouvoir vous faire soumises ou parce que
vous êtes mes chéris les cherry on va
jouer avec l'habile à nabila ma chérie
c'est des questions de culture générale
par ailleurs attention on va jouer avec
une première question à 100 euros
jean michel maire qui sent la pub une
vannerie puristes auraient monnayé
vraiment la vannerie
mais christina a benn et qu'est-ce qu'il
est lourd sans vous allez allez nabila
question console première keita si je
fais cuire à 9,10 mendy minutes
comment sera-t-il à bof bof
j'vais pas ouf c'est dur
des mots comme les glaoui de gens et
demi de matthieu delormeau vent nom
qu'on leur nombre
[Musique]
damien thomas qui jouent avec moi j'aime
bien sûr pour soi est facile at il dit
d'ailleurs si je fais cuire un oeuf
comment sera-t-il baup pas au futur ou
comme les greens de leurs mots tu dis
très bien eh bien c'est la réponse et
c'est dur 100 euros pour la ville à
celle avec qui j'ai brigade
[Musique]
deuxième question
une question pour 200 euros nabila
l'autoroute à 10 heures relie kehl ville
paris bordeaux paris brest paris
sportifs ou paris s'il tonne
l'autoroute a10 relie kehl ville
paris bordeaux paris brest paris
sportifs ou pas miss hilton c'est pour
200 euros nabila je rappelle que tu as
trois joker dans l'appel à merzouga
c'est à dire qu'on pourrait appeler
bouder je peux faire l'appel un ami
j'appellerais un ami à moi qui a
peut-être la réponse foutu à la réponse
au pif ou gilles verdez aura là la
réponse sur son délit ce que tu veux
prendre un joker non il avait donc
parler bordeaux par le juge jean-michel
pas régresser moitié par les villages
l'adorent soin de commenter la raison on
le fait moins de leur bol a relevé mois
de leur - jean-michel à merci enlevez
les mois merci au lever les mois pour
l'instant voilà merci vous les enlevez
merci merci voilà vous et c'est dhabi la
secousse voilà ma chérie alors paris
bordeaux paris brest par les sorties ou
paris s'il tonne
nabila tu vas joker manabi allez tu veux
prendre quoi alors il ya l'appel à un
ami
c'est mr ou mme blanchard est à la peine
en bourse ou burchard de la peine
d'aller où la réponse au pif
la réponse sera noté sur le dé de gilles
verdez je prends quoi
tu m'appelles merzouk allez on appelle
tout de suite merzoug blanchard c'est
parti si l'appel à merzouga
merzouk est déjà là le jardin ilan pappe
les perdre
merzouk merci d'être avec nous mais
ryung merci à 60
on a 60 secondes pour te poser la
question merzouk j'écoute l'autoroute
l'autoroute a10 rosie quelle ville paris
bordeaux paris brest par des sports qui
font pas mais s'il tonne ab j'ai la
réponse en plus pour un village là
dedans
paris bordeaux paris bordeaux nabil est
ce que tu suis merzouk berbère ou
blanche à m donc tu dis la réponse à
paris bordeaux et bien c'est une bonne
réponse tutour remercier mr du gothard
et grâce à nabila on a 2 sur wii pour
les hôpitaux de paris et les hôpitaux de
france
merci merci merci nous bouder troisième
question
prenez une question pour 500 euros la
vie la vraie si la question
et attention tu pour atteindre un
premier palier de 500 dans la série 10%
la série 10% sur france 2 quel métier
est mise à l'honneur les réparateurs de
batterie d'iphone réponse marc les ponce
b les agents de comédiens réponses et
les inspecteurs des impôts ou réponse
dès les avocats qui s'occupent des
divorces de benjamin castaldi
c'est pour 500 euros l'habile as tu
encore deux jokers thual appelle un ami
ou la réponse au pif qui sera noté sur
le lait de gilles verdez tu choisis et
jammes c'est une série que j'adore je
vais dire la réponse de la république et
donc les agents de comédiens la cgt
c'est ton dernier mot nabila gpra
dimension la bulle a c'est une bonne
répondre les agents de comédiens et
nabila tu remportes quoi qu'il arrive
500 euros pour les opérer par les
hôpitaux france puisque c'est notre
premier panier nabila qui peut gagner
jusqu'à 10000 euros pour les hôpitaux de
la ville à qui ça ça se passe bien pour
elle elle a déjà répondu à trois
questions elle a utilisé un joker et
lyon reste encore deux et on passe à la
quatrième question à 750 euros nabila
laquelle de ses chansons n'est pas tirée
de la comédie musicale les dix
commandements la peine maximum l'envi
des mets mon frère où les rois du monde
laquelle de ces chansons n'est pas tirée
de la comédie musicale les dix
commandements vous jouez chez vous
également à la peine maximum bel envie
d'aimer c'est mon frère ou des les rois
du monde
nabila c'est toujours à moi réponse oui
toujours à toi ya que toi qui joues
ok mais est ce que tu vas joker non non
non je crois que ça va le faire parce
que j'ai déjà vu un extrait et jeudi
les voyous les rois du monde
la dernière nabila nabila est ce que tu
aurais peut-être pas dû prendre un joker
je te rappelle que si tu perds tu
redescendre à t-on pas lié à 500 si tu
gagneras 750 euros pour les hôpitaux de
paris et les hôpitaux de france
est ce que tu peux le dire c'est mon
dernier mot baba c'est au dernier mot
dabila ouais c'est quand même mon
dernier en siégeant titre sur donc tu me
dis c'est mon dernier mot baba tu es mon
dernier mandat
réponse dès la bile à la peine maximum
et bien une chanson de la comédie
musicale les dix commandements l'envi
d'aimer et bien une chanson tirée de la
comédie musicale les dix commandements
mon frère est bien tirée de la comédie
musicale les dix commandements
mais les rois du monde c'était roméo et
juliette très bonne réponse de david à
750 euros on habille la brasserie nabila
qui est exceptionnel pour l'instant on
passe à la cinquième question et on joue
pour 1000 euros
je rappelle qu'il reste encore deux
joker à nabila il lui reste six
questions pour arriver aux 10 millions
nabila laquelle de ces stations
ces stations de métro de la ligne 10 du
métro parisien ici ça fait trop
alors c'est bien les quatre stations
laquelle de ces stations de la ligne 10
du métro parisien existe réponse à anz
mercedes réponse b gunther vole vos
réponses et andré citroën
réponse d abd el kader peugeot au japon
1000 euros laquelle de ces stations de
la ligne 10 du métro parisien existe oms
mercedes bunter volvo andré citroën où
abdelkader peugeot mais déjà assez que
des nombreux action comprend pas son
bail déjà mais déjà ça c'est le thème
assez le thème 5 et je pense que tu peux
tu peux emmener diminué ces dix
voilà merci merci la bu la tasse et
bachiri nabil shérif alors il 13,3
réponse est ce que tu veux un joker il
tresse d'appel un ami ou la réponse au
pis si la réponse au pif
c'est gilles verdez qui va te la donner
est ce que tu vas bloquer ou est-ce que
tu décides de réponse à prendre de
risques c'est quand même une bonne cause
du hockey tu prends quelques jokers
pages il
pourquoi tu prends alors gilts aura la
réponse directe moi j'aurais pris gym si
j'étais toi mais me dit il à dire qu'ils
n'ont il aura la réponse marqué sur son
pif donc normalement sa doublette gilles
verdez c'est le deuxième de kerbala bill
haas est la réponse au pif
gilles verdez quelle est la bonne
réponse il donnera son avis avec la
réponse marqué sur son pays gilles et
vous deviez ne revoit pas photo clôture
monte un peu
je revois pas recule un peu sur la tête
de ma mère il année on dirait une piste
de ski contraire trop son forfait pour
lui parler c'est un radis thomas peux tu
vois la lettre ou pas que l'a décidé la
villa sur son museau sur son nez remonte
à peu remonter encore le lait alors la
lune alors nabila est ce que tu peux
donner sa réponse à ce que tu l'as vue
là on voit bien regard apparemment c'est
pas c'est pas beau c'est énorme
palmarès 1 c c'est ainsi au québec voilà
un c docu dit la réponse est donc la
caisse de ses stations de la ligne 10 du
métro parisien existe en tirer des
scooters vols violences mais c'est très
doux à kader peugeot la biladi la
réponse c'est andré citroën et tu peux
remercier gilles c'est une bonne réponse
la ville a tué à 1000 euros euros
paris et les hôpitaux de france nabila
on va passer à la sixième question et tu
vas pouvoir accéder au deuxième palier
sixième question pour 1500 euros si tu
répondu à cette question
quoi qu'il arrive on donnera 1500 euros
pour les hôpitaux de paris et des
hôpitaux de france attention question
quelle ville rendue célèbre par raphaël
mezrahi se trouve dans le département
numéro 10 tous jouent également chez o3b
c'est mon cul des dons je rappelle qu'au
montcuq et une vraie vie non mais c'est
une ville je le dis c'est vrai mais
c'est vrai la friche et ouais alors
nabila il te reste encore un joker c'est
l'appel à m
et je te le dis l'ami que j'appellerais
ce sera jean pierre foucault ah ouais je
voulais pas utiliser jean-pierre tout de
suite
est-ce que voilà mais c'était quoi les
nôtres
je te rappelle la question quelle ville
rendue célèbre par raphaël mezrahi opus
rappelle mezrahi et a dépêché un jour
pour tpmr le glas exactement quelle
ville rendue célèbre par raphaël mezrahi
et se trouve dans le département numéro
10 à 3 b 7
la ville de sète c'est la ville de mon
pull ou des dreux le départ comme une
lumière très source c'est très chaud
très chaud
tu veux que j'appelle jean pierre
foucault parce que l'assainissement ce
que jean-pierre il saura j'en perds y
est allé j'appelle tout de suite l'appel
à un ami
et j'appelle le taulier des tauliers
note jean pierre foucault d'amour c'est
parti je l'appelle on appelle jean
pierre
alors oui c'est monsieur adou dames
c'est le patron qui a percuté le 4 du
team à gagner des millions elle embrasse
également je sais que vous l'embrassez
bon jean pierre merci d'être avec nous
ce qu'on joue pour les hôpitaux de paris
hôpitaux de france
on joue ici à qui veut gagner des
millions parce que les millions on n'en
a pas on joue avec nabil actu peut
saluer nabila qui est très heureux de
t'avoir au téléphone il m des agents
paiera dhabi la voix la bâtisse trop
trop trop de gens bien jean-pierre
nabina but sur une question à 1500 euros
opus est un des pas guy la question la
voici
jean pierre tu as 30 secondes pour
répondre parce qu'on a moins de temps
que sur tf1 quelle ville rendue célèbre
par raphaël mezrahi se trouve dans le
département numéro 10 il 3,7
mon cul ou dreux oui c'est ça les
lacunes laquelle oui nabila jean-pierre
te dit roy est-ce que tu suis jean
pierre foucault ou pas tu te suit des
yeux fermés jean pierre foucault dans le
département du dc n'y a pas de rue dans
le département du 10 il n'ya pas mon cul
il n'est jamais là bas dans le
département du 10 il n'y a pas cette
parce qu'on peut pas avoir cette a dit
exactement en revanche il l'a dit jean
pierre troyes dans l'aube
c'est une bonne réponse
jean-pierre vous pourrez remercier jean
pierre 1500 euros pour nabila et c'était
son palier quoi qu'il arrive elle
remporte 1500 euros elle n'a plus de
joker jean pierre je te fais un énorme
bisou d'amour jean pierre je te fais un
gros bisou store et tu me manques et
labit la thur remercie très forte en
boîte jean pierre foucault voilà vous
allez lui c'est clair c'était précis
c'est carré on aime jean pierre foucault
nabila tu viens de remporter quoi qu'il
arrive et on peut te remercier 1500
euros pour les hôpitaux de
paris-hôpitaux de normes c'est sûr et
certain
tu as gagné 1500 euros tu vas pouvoir
gagner maintenant jusqu'à 10000 euros
mais tu n'as plus de joker attention
nabila c'est une question à 3000 euros
et nabil est ce que tu es fan de booba
c'est que c'est mon pote c'est sur celui
ci tu connais toutes ses chansons par
coeur
eh bien ça tombe bien parce que tu vas
jouer pour 3000 euros tu n'as plus de
joker voici la question dabila est-ce
que tu connais la quête de la leçon
numéro 10 de booba bien sur steam tu
peux nous l'a chanté un peu alors je
vais te dire voici la question nabila
souple et et les paroles de numéro 10 de
booba j'attends pas que ça tombe du ciel
si c'est pas numéro 10 à paname t à la
banane du siècle je suis sûr et là tu
attends je vais donner toutes les
propositions
donc si ça tombe pas du ciel c'est pas
numéro 6 est pas numéro 10 à paname t la
banane du siècle réponse à la frangipane
deuxième réponse des deux fois ci je ne
construis réponse est 'oui' la bal trad
le boulvé réponse des poursuites nous
dit quoi nabila la banane du siec tu es
sûr de ta réponse oui oui tu as well as
tu prends aucun risque
quoi qu'il arrive à 1500 euros donc si
tu gagnes tu remportes 3000 euros si tu
perds tu resteras 1500 euros donc tu
prends en carrière
nabila tu me dis 3000 euros pour 3000
euros tu me dis la banane du siècle
nabila oui c'est ça la banane du siècle
c'est une bonne réponse trois mines au
vent pour la ville abreu
[Musique]
nabiha qu'il gagne 3000 euros pour les
hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de france
l'habit là il te reste encore trois
questions pour atteindre les 10 millions
voici la huitième question j'ai remarqué
on joue pour les 10 ans et pépé dont
toutes les questions en rapport avec le
chiffre 10 ce numéro 10 est le plus
célèbre numéro 10 de l'équipe de france
de foot
zidane c'est zidane c'est zidane
non voici la question pour 5000 euros
zidane y porter quel numéro sur son
maillot au real de madrid le numéro 21
le 10 le 5 ou le sect le 21 le 10 le 5
ou le sect la ville a toujours peur 5000
euros alors comme mon mari est un grand
fan et qui me rend mal les matches en
comptant tout le temps je connais toutes
les cendres et du coup je crois d'après
mes mémoires que zidane au real
le numéro est sage le numéro 5
la bella tu joues pour 5 millions si tu
perds tu redescendre à l'actu 3000 euros
mais si tu perds tu redescends grâce au
palier inférieur à 1500 euros nabila et
là je me dis le 5
nabila ce que tu me dis que c'est mon
est ce que tu peux me dire c'est mon
dernier mot baba simon le numéro un
c'est ce que tu peux dire c'est mon
dernier mot babala 6
pour que je valide sa réponse si vous
avez dit mot nabila je vais te dire moi
j'ai dit et je sais que c'est pas c'est
pas le set
je sais que c'est pas lundi mais nabil
art nabila le 21 ça dit pas quelque
chose à thomas nabila tu m'as dit la
réponse 5le 5,05 vidal au real madrid
est ce que tu vas gagner les 1500 les
5000 euros
ou est-ce que tu redescends à 1500 euros
nabila je te donne la réponse
dans un instant
merci d'être avec nous c'est ce soir
chez ba ba le seule nation en direct de
chez moi avec nabil art et thomas qui
sont avec nous pour jouer pour les
hôpitaux de paris et des hôpitaux de
france je joue à qui veut gagner des
milliers et pour l'instant ça se passe
très très bien pour nabila elle peut
gagner jusqu'à 10000 euros en dix
questions pour l'instant nabila a gagné
[Musique]
5000 au peut-être ou peut-être pas ce
que nabila pour l'instant tu as 3000
euros est jetée poser une question il ya
un instant le plus célèbre numéro 10 de
l'équipe de france de foot
zidane porter quel numéro sur son
maillot au real de madrid
c'est qu'en équipe de france c'était le
numéro 10 donc je t'avais donné comme
réponse le numéro 21 le numéro 10 le
numéro 5 ou le numéro 7
le numéro 10 et en est-il de france dont
pour les limites le numéro 7
c'est pas ça non plus le numéro 5 ou le
numéro 21
si ça n'est pas le 5
l'habile à turow descendra à 1500 euros
en revanche si c'est le 5 tu gagneras
5000 euros pour les hôpitaux de paris
hôpitaux de france
[Musique]
nabila zinedine zidane a porté le numéro
il a porté le numéro 21 10 10 la messe
que c'était au real madrid
non c'est un jeu wii il portait le
numéro 21 à la juventus de turin
exactement votre joue à la juventus et
au real madrid
il portait le numéro 5 puisqu'il a
récupéré le numéro d'une légende du club
alfredo di stefano voilà et donc nappy
la très bonne réponse a dit laurence de
labinal la ville reine
conporec on peut remarquer thomas son
mari que j'aime fort aussi mon thomas
bravo chéri brad hawpe chéri d'amour
nabila tu à 5000 euros et tu vas tout de
suite tenté la question l'avant dernière
question à 7 millions nabila voici la
question du jour pour les hôpitaux de
paris hôpitaux de france si vous nous
rejoignez on est en direct ce soir chez
ba ba
question quelle émission a fait
plus de 10 millions de téléspectateurs
4 réponses la finale de secret story 1
la finale de la star ac 1
un prime spécial
attention à la marche avec jean luc
reichmann en 2003 où la finale de koh
lanta en 2007
tu n'as plus de joker nabila sais c'est
dur ça et oui quelle mission a fait plus
de 10 millions de téléspectateurs on
joue pour 7000 euros c'est l'avant
dernière question normal que ce soit dur
vous jouez avec nous chez vous ou zouk
avec le chiffre 10 quelle émission a
fait plus de 10 millions de
téléspectateurs à la finale de secret
story 1 b la finale de la star ac 1
c'est le prime spéciale attention à la
marche avec jean luc reichmann en 2003
ou des la finale de koh lanta en 2007
nabila pour l'instant tu à 5000 euros
pour les hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux pied
la ville à qui tu peux dire tu peux me
dire je m'arrête là j'ai plus de joker
je prends pas de risques parce que si tu
donnes une mauvaise réponse là tu
redescends à 1500 alors déjà j'hésite
entre super cougar a pris alors la bile
à ce que je peux te dire nabila c'est
que c'est entre les deux
ah ouais voilà c'était ça j'étais sûr
déjà de base visites entre la finale de
la star ac 1 et la finale de koh lanta
en 2007
quelle émission a fait plus de 10
millions de téléspectateurs
la finale de la star ac 1 c'était c'est
une non c'est exactement avec jennifer
jean pascal mais bon j'espère la ville
en lice n'ont plus la villa sait où tu
remportes 7000 euros et tu joues avec la
dernière question à dix mille ou bien tu
redescends à 1500 euros si c'est pas une
bonne réplique dont la villa que je
rêvais de seconde de compte dans les
chiffres que je réfléchisse à l'est il
faut une réponse nabila à légumes dits
finale de la star ac 1 en finale de koh
lanta c'est ok j'ai compris je pense je
pense qu'on pense et je suis prêt sinon
sûr que c'est la finale de la série
finale de la star ac 1 nabila est ce que
c'est ton dernier mode habile à ce que
tu peux me dire si tu valides cette
réponse c'est mon dernier mot bab al
aziz
qu'est ce que tu as dit nabila on joue
pour 7000 au dhabi là tu va redescendre
à 1500 euros pour les hôpitaux de paris
risqués ou bien l'habit là tu seras à
7000 euros étudiants du centre à la
dernière question a dit nous sache que
la question était qu'à l'émission a fait
plus de 10 millions de téléspectateurs
le prime attention à la marche
le record c'était en janvier 2003 en
prime bravo à bonjour luc reichmann
d'ailleurs il avait fait 8 millions de
téléspectateurs
donc ça n'est pas ça la finale de secret
story 1 avec benjamin castaldi
c'était le record c'est ça effet
benjamin ou 7,5 millions de
téléspectateurs 7 millions de
téléspectateurs exactions c'est déjà
énorme
tu hésité entre la finale de koh lanta
en 2007 où la finale de la star ac st
avec jennifer avec jean-pascal de ces
tirs
nabila si c'est la finale de koh lanta
tu redescends à 1500 euros
j'aurais quand même fait gagner 1500
euros pour les hôpitaux de paris
hôpitaux de france
l'habile à ma chérie malheureusement la
finale de koh lanta en 2007 avait fait
un énorme carton nabila
puisque la finale de koh lanta en 2007
malheureusement avait fait 9,4 millions
de téléspectateurs et c'est une bonne
réponse de nabila c'est la finale de la
star ac afn 10 millions dt je n'adhère
plus de 10 millions téléspectateurs
l'habile à nabila tué à 7000 euros pour
les hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de france
on peut dire la bilhac exception
attention nabila tu vas jouer maintenant
pour la dernière question et tu vas
jouer à qui veut gagner des milliers
c'est la dernière question pour 10000
aurait olabi la voici la question pour
10000 euros
tu n'as plus de joker nabila est ce que
tu vas faire remporter dix mille euros
aux hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de france
je vous le dit nabila elle joue à fond
elle est exceptionnelle on est fier
d'elle une fois de plus très bien
question pour nabila parmi ces
personnalités
laquelle n'est pas dans le top 10 des
personnalités préférées des enfants
c'était dans le journal de mickey
ils ont de 7 à 14 ans parmi ces
personnalités laquelle n'est pas dans le
top 10 des personnalités préférées des
enfants
réponse à soprano
non réponse b antoine griezmann réponse
c'est eric antoine
réponse dès mpokora soutry quand c'est
dur s'il vous plaît alors parmi ces
personnalités laquelle n'est pas dans le
top 10 des personnalités préférées des
enfants une sur journal de mickey 2020
ça vient de sortir ce sondage c'est un
vote de 7 à 14 ans réponse à soprano
réponse b antoine griezmann réponse eric
antoine réponse dès m pokora nabila tu
peux me dire ma chérie j'arrête là et je
repars avec les 7000 euros pour les
hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de france où
tu le dis je veux tenter les 10000 euros
au risque de retomber à 1500 euros
dabila alors laquelle de ces
personnalités n'est pas dans le top 10
des personnalités préférées des enfants
soprano antoine griezmann héricourtois m
pokora bilan je t'attends plus du tout
nabila on n'entend plus nabila
malheureusement antoine conte donc alors
si vous blesser un compte aller
nabila je t'entends plus nabila est ce
qu'on peut on va bannaby là ce que tu
m'entends nabila qui joue pour dit milo
je vous rappelle la question si vous
nous rejoignez le temps que nab hilare
règle de tout ça parmi ces personnalités
laquelle n'est pas dans le top 10 des
personnalités préférées des enfants
soprano antoine griezmann eric antoine
twente au cora alors nabila fais moi
signe avec ta main si tu veux on me dira
la réponse que tu veux donner déjà
nabila est ce que tu veux tenter des 10
millions si tu me lever le pouce en
l'air ça veut dire oui on voit plus on
n'entend plus habiles à les chéris
nabila a remporté pour l'instant c'est
ce milieu pour les hôpitaux de paris les
hôpitaux de france on va prendre
c'est gilles verdez qui va prendre la
décision pour nabil un baril parce que
tu es le plus proche d'elle avec moi
parce que la ville entend plonger c'est
de l'avoir dans un instant gilles est ce
que tu continues est ce que tu tentes
les 10000 euros
ou bien est-ce que tu me dis non labit
l'aaf un travail exceptionnel a déjà
remporté sept mille euros et je m'arrête
là parce que sinon je redescends à 1500
euros
alors mon problème sert il sait que je
sais que griezmann et soprano sont dans
les personnalités mais j'ai un gros
doute entre eric antoine et matt pokora
j'ai un énorme doute donc je pense que
le plus raisonnable parce qu'il ya un
gros différentiel entre 1500 et 7000 je
pense vu le raisonnable serait de
s'arrêter à sept mille et une
fantastique somme est ma ville a été
tellement extraordinaire seulement
boulet bêtement gâché ce qu'elle a fait
est fantastique
l'onudc mots alors liberté et juste
gilbert d'instaurer pour dubois
j'aurais produire et aurait pu et aurait
répondu eric antoine gilles tu as pris
la décision pour nabila parce qu'on a eu
des liaisons avec nabil à nabila et
retour à bavois labit la wiimote ou ma
chérie ma chérie j'avais jamais pris
gilles avec qui tu es extrêmement potes
et que tu adores pour te représenter
comme on s'entendait plus gilles avait
pris la décision de s'arrêter à 7000 au
doigt qu'est ce que tu me dis tu veux
tenter les 10000 euros ou tu me dis non
j'arrête là je parle des sondages et sa
santé les huit halls alors nabila
parmi ces personnalités laquelle n'est
pas dans le top 10 des personnalités
préférées des enfants
soprano antoine griezmann eric antoine
ou m pokora mboma gilles avait dit eric
antoine
les génériques antoine moins qu'antoine
le magicien l'animateur de m6 conte à
doha le ciel est justement les chances
qu'il y ait de matt pokora et elle peut
croire avec très aimé aussi oui mais ô
combien faire un choix si tu ne sait pas
garder cette date il viendra montrer
l'alliance à elle et nabila tu me dis m
pokora
oui même temps qu'est ce que est ce que
c'est ton dernier mot c'est mon amant
elle que je peux dire c'est mon dernier
mot bab al aziz c'est mon dernier me
balade alors nabila je te le dis sur les
réseaux sociaux ya plein de gens qui
disent je suis sûr qu'elle a été regardé
si c'est la bonne réponse alors je ne
crois pas mais voilà un
voilà un bon alors
je sais pas si c'est la bonne réponse ou
pas mais en tout cas je valide sa
réponse nabila si tu perds tu va
redescendre à 1500 euros là tu as la
possibilité de gagner 10 mille euros
nabila nabila je répète la question
parmi ces personnalités laquelle n'est
pas dans le top 10 des personnalités
préférées des enfants
soprano bien sûr qu'il y est puisque
c'est même le premier c'est la
personnalité préférée des enfants
soprano que j'embrasse pause forme on
soprin que j'aime
il le sait qu il mérite cette première
place antoine griezmann où notre photo
j'aime fort aussi que j'embrasse qui
doit être confiné et j'irai voir les
matchs reprendront en toile le frère on
tue les 6e
donc il est bien rétabli tu hésites et
et gilles verdez exister avec toi entre
eric antoine et m pokora
la réponse était quelle personnalité
n'est pas dans le top 10 des
personnalités préférées des enfants
m pokora ou eric antoine tu as luc m
pokora n'était pas dans la personnalité
peuvent dans les personnalités préférées
des enfants
nabila tu m'as dit c'est mon dernier mot
bab al aziz
ça veut dire que j'ai dû valider ta
réponse à la réponse des m pokora
l'habile à m pokora et dans les
personnalités préférées des enfants et
17 81 m pokora est 14e
eric antoine septième jeu remporté les
dix mille euros
on les hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux locaux
bravo nabila on devine euros grâce à un
habile à aujourd'hui tout mari au plus
tôt de france voilà grâce à nabila et
voilà c'est ce soir chez ba ba oui la
vie en voyage sécurisés
non je voulais rajouter quelque chose on
aimerait on aimerait donner la même
somme mais aussi aux acheteurs françois
non je vous aime très fort les deux vous
savez quand vous avez mal et devra jouer
voilà vous êtes exceptionnel et je
voudrais dire ce et d'eau sont d'une
générosité incroyable
ils sont heureux on les ailes qui donne
place je vous dis pour les associations
qui font plein de trucs que soit dhabi
là où thomas et le couple est formidable
et vous savez que je vous aime très très
fort le shérif et qu' on est avec vous à
fond et continuez à nous faire kiffer
continuer à faire du bien dix mille
euros
dix mille euros en plus donnés par
nabila et thomas franchement et bravo ce
qui fait donc et 20000 euros pour les
hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de france
c'est pour ça que je les aime les deux
franchement je lisais le trou mais c'est
vrai ici on les aime ça mais je les aime
à dire on les aime aussi les adore ont
regardé ce sourire éclatant
vous voulez que je vous dise vous nous
changer les idées
vous nous amenez du soleil et du bonheur
vous à tous les sens franchement vous
regarde tous les soirs du sida dans le
salon et c'est un leurre ménard et vous
êtes tous géniaux
vraiment on vous aime fort et continuer
comme ça les chirico tiré du bonheur on
vous adore merci déchiré merci claude
labit là qu'on aime forêt et 20000 euros
pour les hôpitaux et franchement c'est
magnifique sony à qui veut gagner
elle est grâce à qui veut gagner des
milliers grâce à nabila